today in our little yellow book she's an
inspiration to all of us you have her on
your wall in your show it's oprah
i love that she said live your best life
how clever is that the turn of phrase
your makes it about you and not about
her and now we have oprah daily which is
like lets you just know you can be on
that feeder and totally satisfied um and
she has a new digital series
on the
oprahdaily.com called the oprah daily
insiders roundtable
it's hosted by the one and only gail
king who's a friend of the show
and mine and with incredible guests like
glennon doyle um ashley c ford talking
about the big issues let's take a look
it's like we have had time to think
about who we are and what we want and
what we will not accept anymore whether
it's stilettos or that jerk that we've
been going to lunch with forever for
some reason it's being fiercely on our
own side and not changing for the world
but like changing our friends and our
clothes to fit us
[Applause]
i
feel like
our conversations could cross over a
hundred thousand percent glenn and doyle
kind of talking fun truths about fashion
and relationships and breaking it all
down in a pithy adorable useful
take-away way
um
i was uh i'm on oprah daly and she
published her journal entry from the
night before
she started the oprah winfrey show oh
wow
so as a journalist
um journalist i wanted to read that
entry so badly so i go to read it and
they're like oh you have to be an oprah
insider to get it and i was like
ah
so are you an oprah insider i want to be
all right well you can be and we are
thrilled because we are teaming up with
oprah daily for an ongoing partnership
oprah daily editors will be sharing the
latest oprah daily scoops here all
season long and we're kicking it off
today
[Applause]
you're all getting a free oprah daily
insider membership
[Applause]
that's the full year of the magazine
digital and all the episodes of oprah
daily insiders roundtable special
invites so much more um so i'm just i'm
i'm thrilled i'm excited to spend every
day with oprah she is an icon but you're
an icon and i'm an icon and you're all
icon that's right
[Applause]
thank you for being the best co-pilot
here today on the news
[Music]